making a direct sequel to a movie
decades later is becoming more common in
Hollywood recently it presents a unique
challenge for directors and
cinematographers as they have to find
the balance between creating something
that feels connected to the original
film while still creating something that
is unique and new from it was usually I
make my movies are here is Denny
Villeneuve the director of Blade Runner
2049 describing his relationship to the
original Blade Runner this is the first
time I was making a movie inspired by
another movie and I didn't try to stay
away from it I just kept it as a Bible
as a reference as as a music that I was
very close to me that I area
I was always referring to him every time
I was directing everyday thinking about
the spirit of the first movie
denne and director of photography Roger
Deakins developed a unique visual style
updating the world and the production
design for a story that takes place long
after the events of the original film
Roger Deakins often abandons the hard
high-contrast lighting of the original
for his more signature soft and diffused
lighting style production design has
been updated to reflect the changes in
the world
but there are still visual connections
the ones I've highlighted here ground
2049 in a familiar space reoccurring
places feel similar and visual motifs
are used to link past and present
characters and themes threading the
needle of being original while remaining
true to the source material must be a
difficult task I think where 2049
succeeds is by making these references
subtly enough that it doesn't feel
formulaic or forced most of the visual
references are made during segments of
the film that are establishing or
transitioning shots
20:49 doesn't lean on these references
to be the weight of the story instead it
uses them to allude to a similar place
and world while building towards a story
that is fresh and new
I'm Thomas light thank you so much for
taking the time to check out this video
in my channel as always a quick thank
you to my patreon supporters they helped
me continue making these videos I often
get asked where I get the music I use in
my videos I want to tell you very
quickly about artless then using art
list for well over a year artless has an
excellent high-quality music library you
only pay an annual subscription fee and
you get unlimited access to the tracks
in the library click the link in the
description to browse the library and
preview some of the tracks and if you
decide sign up it helps support my
channel thanks again for watching hit
that subscribe button or that share
button and I'll talk to you again soon
[Music]